despite television being a very crowded
field right now the police procedural
series ncis
is still going strong in its 18th season
and even today
it's one of the most watched shows in
america loyal viewers have stuck with
the series since its premiere in 2003
and in its 10th season it even surpassed
sunday night football and american idol
to become the highest rated broadcast on
network tv
since that time ncis has never left the
list of top 3 most watched shows in the
country it even inspired two spin-offs
of its own
ncis new orleans and ncis los angeles
both of which are hugely popular in
their own right unsurprisingly for a
massively successful show that's been on
the air for nearly two decades ncis has
also seen its fair share of behind the
scenes drama
perhaps most contentious of all however
was showrunner and creator donald
belisario's sudden departure from the
show in 2007.
after less than five years why would
someone leave such a successful show
and one they created too well let's just
say it wasn't exactly by choice
it's worth knowing a little more about
belisario's background in television
after all his name is practically
synonymous with the medium his writing
career began in 1977 when he earned his
first credit for penning an
episode of the cliff potts lead series
big hawaii on nbc
he continued to bolster his resume
throughout the late 70s as a writer and
director contributing to some of the
most well-known tv shows of the decade
including kojak battlestar galactica and
quincy me
belisario's big break arrived in 1980
when he launched his first series magnum
pi which became a cultural staple for
american tv and established tom selleck
as a household name
the show was an enormous success for cbs
and remained on the air for eight
seasons this was just the beginning of
belisario's working relationship with
the network however which would continue
on and off for nearly 40 years
despite the runaway success of magnum pi
bellisario's name wasn't exactly a
golden ticket to success for his tv
creations
tales of the golden monkey an abc
adventure show attempting to capitalize
on the success of raiders of the lost
ark
aired for only one season in 1982-83
another one of his works was tequila and
bonnetti a cbs comedy drama about an
italian cop and his talking canine
partner
amid poor reviews from critics the
network canceled the show before the
last two of its 12 filmed
episodes could air still after that
rough patch he rebounded with more hits
including the cult favorite science
fiction series quantum leap which
debuted in 1989.
the show survived for four seasons with
the final episode attracting almost 13
million viewers
but his biggest success even above
magnum pi would come in 1995 with the
debut of jag
nbc is probably still kicking themselves
to this day over that one only the first
season of jag
aired on their network and when they
opted to drop the show cbs swooped in
what followed was a popular 10 season
run but more importantly thanks to a
backdoor pilot in season 8 and cis was
born spinning off to quickly become the
juggernaut franchise it is today but
belisario's time with ncis came to a
dramatic end
when in 2007 the show star mark harman
forced him out
according to reports the two butted
heads for months with harman disliking
belisario's quote
chaotic management style and the long
hours that resulted from it the network
decided harman's star power was more
important to the show than belisario's
behind the scenes work
and the latter was subsequently fired
however he retained an executive
producer title on the show which he
still holds today
this wasn't the end of the drama
involving belisario though the ex-show
runner sued cbs after ncis los angeles
entered into production
an existing clause in his contract gave
him the right to create the show's first
spin-off but after his forced departure
from the show cbs hired fellow ncis
executive producer shane brennan to make
it instead needless to say bellisario
was not
okay with this everything is not okay
belisario and cbs ultimately settled out
of court for an
undisclosed amount belisario is now
retired from tv and although he may no
longer be actively involved with ncis
fans still have him to thank for
creating and producing such a
long-running and beloved series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you